- [Voiceover] So we're told
to factor the polynomial below
by its greatest common monomial factor.
So what does that mean?
So we have these two terms,
and I want to figure out
their greatest common monomial factor,
and then I want to express this
with that greatest common
monomial factor factored out.
So how can we tackle it?
Well, one way to start
is I can look at just the constant terms,
or not the constants, the
coefficients, I should say.
So I have the 8 and the 12.
Then I could say,
"Well, what is just the greatest
common factor of 8 and 12?"
The gcf of 8 and 12.
And there are a lot of
common factors of 8 and 12.
They're both divisible by 1,
they're both divisible by 2,
they're both divisible by 4.
But the greatest of their
common factors is going to be 4.
So that is equal to 4.
So, let me just leave that there.
And then we could think
about, "What is...?"
Well, let me actually
write it right over here.
I'll put a 4 here.
And now we can move on to the powers of x.
We have an x squared and we have an x.
And we could say,
"What is the largest power
of x that is divisible
into both x squared and x?"
Well, that's just going to be x.
x squared is clearly divisible by x,
and x is clearly divisible by x,
but x isn't going to have a
larger power of x as a factor.
So this is the greatest
common monomial factor
of x squared and x.
Now we do the same thing for the ys.
So, we have a y and a y squared.
If we think in the same terms
the largest power of y that's
divisible into both of these
is going to be just y to
the first power, or y.
And so 4xy is the greatest
common monomial factor.
And to see that we could
express each of these terms
as a product of 4xy and something else.
So this first term right over here,
so let me pick a color,
so this term right over
here we could write as 4xy.
That one's actually,
that color's hard to see,
let me pick a darker color.
We could write this right
over here as 4xy times what?
And I encourage you to pause
the video and think about that.
Let's see, 4 times what
is going to get us to 8?
Well, 4 times 2 is going to get us to 8.
x times what is going
to get us to x squared?
Well, x times x is going
to get us to x squared.
And then y times what
is going to get us to y?
Well, it's just going to be y.
So 4xy times 2x is
actually going to give us
this first term.
So actually just let me rewrite
a little bit differently.
So it's 4xy times 2x is this first term,
and you can verify that.
4 times 2 is going to be equal to 8,
x times x is equal to x squared,
and then you just have the y.
Now let's do the same
thing with the second term.
And I just want to do this to show you
that this is their largest
common monomial factor.
So the second term,
and I'll do this in a
slightly different color,
do it in blue.
I want to write this as the product of 4xy
and another monomial.
So 4 times what is 12?
Well, 4 times 3 is 12.
x times what is x?
Well, it's just going to be 1,
so we don't have to write a times 1 here.
And then y times what is y squared?
It's going to be y times y is y squared.
And you can verify.
If you multiply these two you're
going to get 12 xy-squared.
4 times 3 is 12, you get your x,
and then y times y is y squared.
So, so far I've written
this exact same expression
but I've taken each of those
terms and I've factored them
into their greatest common monomial factor
and then whatever is left over.
And now I can factor the 4xy out.
I can actually factor it out.
So this is going to be equal to,
if I factor the 4xys out,
you can kind of say I
undistribute the 4xy.
I factor it out.
This is going to be equal
to 4xy times 2x plus --
when I factor 4xy from here
I get the 3y left over.
Plus 3y, and we're done.
And you can verify it.
If you were to go the other way,
if you were to distribute this 4xy
and multiply it times 2x,
you would get 8 x-squared y.
And then when you distribute
the 4xy onto the 3y
you get the 12xy-squared.
And so we're done.
This right over here is our answer.
The answer is going to be 4xy,
which is the greatest
common monomial factor,
times 2x plus 3y.